captain phillips starring tom hanks
trust me it is not the film you thought
it would be if you're going in like me
thinking you're about to see
philadelphia part two
you are wrong
this is the first time i'm gonna be
doing a review with my family watching
me i'm kind of uncomfortable right now
because if you've seen this show before
you don't want to make jokes like this
in front of your family captain phillips
is one of the best movies of the year
according to everybody else personally
it's not one of my favorites but i can
totally see why everyone else is really
digging the film it's
dark it's moody it's really tension
filled you know it's really raw
realistic as ever truly powerful biopic
sure let's just
start off with the one thing everybody
seems to be in agreeance on that of
course being
thomas hanks aka tom hanks who is best
known for his portrayal of 16 different
people
in cloud atlas and the polar express but
who really launched the fame with
the da vinci code yep these are all
facts anyway tom hanks plays the title
character captain phillips and how is he
in the role well tom makes he [ __ ]
rocks it man
i get uncomfortable to say the f word
around my mom ever since the strong
portrayal of woody and toy story 3 i
have been waiting for a performance to
live up to that
level and this comes rather close it's a
little bit better it starts off with tom
hanks it's just regular american joe you
know he's got a family he's got
kids he's got a wife who's not looking
like such good wife material anymore you
know and captain phillips has to do his
job and transport cargo across some
dangerous seas
where he soon realizes somali pirates
are coming after him can you imagine
that for just a second but just some
molly pirates coming after you
would you piss or [ __ ] this is the kind
of humor my mother taught me honestly it
was until the very end of the film where
i realized what everyone was talking
about with tom hanks's performance i
mean i'm not gonna like ruin the ending
for you
tommyx dies captain phillips dies then
he you know lives in the afterlife and
then he writes his book which this movie
is based on
okay i'm not going to say if he dies or
not but if you know that the true story
it's not going to ruin anything for you
anyway the whole time i was watching
this film
i was like why is tom hanks getting his
like dick sucked by every movie critic
out there but by the end it just
hits you it's not necessarily a film
where it's like you watch
captain phillips start off as this like
one guy then by the end of the journey
he's like this completely different
fella
the film is like about the traumatic
impact it takes on captain phillips
because let's face it
he had a pretty shitty day that day and
now he has to live with this horrible
experience
i don't know why i'm laughing well it's
kind of funny somali pirates come on
it's realistic but it's subtle and it's
a powerful performance honestly by the
end tom hanks had me tearing up i was
crying again kind of like when i saw the
box office numbers for larry crown
no one saw that movie i just want to see
a movie where tom hanks plays
a captain with aids who is telling his
story on a bench so yes to wrap it up
absolutely tom hanks he totally deserves
the oscar nomination the other awesome
player
captain somali not salami no
no no i don't know the real actor's name
but i'm kind of okay with that i'm glad
they cast more of an
unknown guy it makes the villain that
much easier to believe and i just love
the way the villain was like portrayed
like captain somali is not like just a
one-dimensional
villain who's got only one thing on his
mind it's strange because they don't
necessarily give him a lot of backstory
nor do they show too much of his
lifestyle before the event but for some
reason you
actually get where this guy is coming
from i mean you're not like rooting for
the guy but you are like
yes captain somalia i want you to get
your money just
i don't want you to kill white people
but yeah captain somalia he's awesome
the interplay between him and tom hanks
is great this guy just
looks and sounds like a real somali
pirate i know this because i know plenty
of somali pirates his teeth his
skinny lengthy body the way he comes
across everything about him feels so
authentic
and i feel like his performance is going
to be overlooked why does the world
treat black people this way this film
has some solid directing from paul
greengrass
paul greengrass that could be the name
of a weed anyway paul greengrass is back
doing his thing you know the ridiculous
handheld shots getting that documentary
feel in there and it's
completely effective in this film but
i'm not gonna lie in act one i had
difficulty getting into it yeah it moves
kind of slow
really establishing like tone and
characters but when like [ __ ] starts to
hit the fan
that's when it gets really good but i
felt like it could have been 10 times
more effective if it wasn't so apparent
that paul greengrass was directing this
he's a great director he really knows
how to work with his actors he you know
probably pisses off his editor with all
the coverage he gets but let's get real
here
let's get straight to the point here he
shoots like all his [ __ ] films the
same way
born supremacy born ultimatum in 1993.
now this thing i just had difficulty at
first getting immersed in the experience
because for a large chunk of it i was
like
yeah paul greengrass is definitely
directing this movie it'd probably be
more immersive if i smoked some paul
greengrass before the movie the
directing the cinematography the editing
is all great i would just like mr
handheld documentary [ __ ] to you
know
make a different type of film for a
change and you combine the talent with
the clever script you get one hell of a
film anyway it doesn't play i like how
you think it would it's it's slow moving
but tension filled
and thrilling it's strongly emotionally
driven the plot turns that occur they're
[ __ ] awesome it takes place
essentially in real time and it's like
the camera is just
capturing the experience it just keeps
you wondering like what's gonna happen
next
until you remember what the [ __ ]
trailer showed you last thing to mention
awesome [ __ ] score i'd have sex with
captain robert langdon with aids
on that bench while listening to this
score let me get straight to the point
here oh and all i gotta say captain
phillips got it super right
all right guys thanks for checking out
my review for captain phillips why don't
you go ahead
scroll that comment box below and tell
me
i don't know did you like the movie
anybody go ahead and follow me on
twitter you click this button right here
you see all you gotta do is click it
it's one click
why are none of you clicking it and if
you want to see a more in-depth review
of captain phillips why don't you go
ahead and check out my show called
reasons to see
that i do with my buddy jerry
i know he needs to shave and last but
not least if you want to get updated
every time one of my reviews is out go
ahead and click on this button on my
penis to subscribe
that's right is this captain phillips
ship
he ain't going down
you